hello everyone  or is it hello again welcome to the  create your own  zelda direct for the 35th anniversary of  the legend of zelda franchise  in this fan made presentation you will  be given the unique opportunity  to choose which announcement to fit  inside your  very own zelda direct  each choice is very exciting  so please do your best to choose what  best fits  your tastes  and at the end of the presentation we  may have prepared a special announcement  who knows i guess there's only one way  to find out  hello there general kenobi  i'm sure a lot of you saw me and thought  there might be news about the sequel to  the legend of zelda breath of the wild  game  fortunately we do have something very  big  about the sequel to share with you at  this time  please enjoy this announcement  you